[Musik]
das gut miteinander und herzlich
willkommen bei kochen lernen mit showa
shell der kochschule mit dem
spitzengastronom dem sternekoch und dem
koch aller köche zu wasser und das bin
ich
ja schon möglich dass interessierte
bekommen
sie müsste ich heute ein bisschen
wichtig mal hatte
apropos wichtig heute geht es um ein
ernstes thema in der küche ein thema das
immer wieder zu tränen führt es geht ums
zwiebelschneiden der wert auf du mal an
blickt wir bei einem rosamunde pilcher
film
[Musik]
moschino groß ist jetzt muss er bei der
wunde mädchen sie immer wenn
ja wie schon recht jetzt hat also wir
waren beim
zwiebelschneiden
kriegst du jetzt langsam
auswärtsmatch
beim zwiebelschneiden und zwar ohne
tränen
zwiebelschneiden ohne tränen wie geht
das doch gibt es unter den anfängern die
kuriosesten tricks tipps zum beispiel
dass man beim zwiebelschneiden einschlug
himbeergeist
oder
oder das mit einem 12 schneider kopf in
den usa weiter dies ist ein telegramm
profi macht dieses so
also auf geht's schneiden
wir sonst das ist der trick monster
steine hier aufsteiger die ganzen scheiß
moment und wenn sie mehr profi tricks
von uns erfahren möchten dann schalten
sie wieder ein bei kochen lernen mit
der zeit nichts wissen
[Applaus]